hi guys today I have a very special game
for you it's something a little bit
different it's not horror it has been
out for a while it's called fun or three
and I'm really excited about this
because basically I grew up playing
point and click games such as
machinarium it's one of my favorite
games I haven't paid it on this channel
but it was a game that I played a long
time ago and this is why the same people
they also made a summer off one which
was a web game and they made a son off
to they sure did play when I was younger
as well another sunrise 3 it's a quirky
cool pointing Clint game I think this
will be good it'll be another one where
I can hopefully read the narrative and
we can explore weird and quirky things
who's going to be a good let's meet the
students together I love the upsell for
all these games as well machinarium
really inspired a lot of the art that I
do oh yeah okay look at the bunny oh oh
oh the other thing is all because it's
been so long I don't you know what
happened in the other games but I'm
pretty sure we can play this one and not
have to remember the others I'm sure we
find is
[Music]
Kevin ok so I scroll in to look around
then I hold this oh I see oh ok and I
can make him walk places did you do the
site you want me to sing to the trees
listening history Wow alright so I don't
really know what that's it oh he's
listening closer to the wood wood
chipper what the hell is that bread cord
I am I can't remember oh my gosh I'm an
idiot
ah kid I want the dog let's go over here
and we can play with the funny
no none of them want to play okay then I
guess we start our journey let me give
this week yes it looks so much like
missionary missionary was a bit point
clicking about a little robot and he was
durable and ah well I guess it's
Maybelline peoples of course it will be
the same kind of stuff yeah and like any
good point and click game there are a
lot of puzzles hmm what do I need to do
here am I getting it over so I can stand
on it is that what I'm doing or am I
trying to knock this guy I think it
might be trying to knock it yeah see
it's making a little Zen this way boom
no who's there not going to work because
if it falls over then I can maybe walk
across yeah there you go I knew what I
was doing it right
Oh
such a cool little deer I love the
little creatures in this game they make
it so weird so weird in the best ways oh
[Music]
sounds really lovely look in always
playing back to them what the hell is
over what what are they turning into
this is mine else Quinn you know I'm
turning the head into little squid squid
shapes like this
[Music]
follow my witnessing an idea goodbye hey
hey good I got you all these mushrooms
are you happy are you gonna share them
with me can I have a mushroom please oh
hello Vijay eating can I eat with you I
want to use this knife I don't know what
I need to use is my fault when I want
it's nice family hey I got those
mushroom to you the least you can do is
let me borrow your knife
do you want to eat with me and it's in a
TPU is that what you just said to me
[Music]
okay so you wanted to eat with me we got
the mushrooms oh oh here we go you want
this one they're really hungry oh
they're really hungry in the 10 so these
two must hunt and find food but then
warm too hun I can't make us use can
they just pick up pick a mushroom nobody
appreciates the mushrooms this is so
cool how did your color believe I did
Anna me just what i love about quirky
little point in clicking okay there's no
fish to be found I guess bernero to a
deer usually go away you got away I
don't know rut the mammoth zero damage
taken what about the two fellows of
spiritual Canady speed ok so that's
interesting he like ran into the fire
what about the pun I you can't do
anything fun hey wait isn't yes thank
you
I'll take said are you going to go yet
the pig know why not give it to the
people all right did I do it there
anything I met Mia does they need to eat
all the animals oh okay right so we know
that you jump over absolutely but can
you jump over a mammoth Clinton
the departed
[Music]
now of course
can you jump on my thighs normal ethical
yes nothing favors faces of mammoth what
a foul we stuck oh mama
[Music]
keeping so cute aha is the bud
yeah took mama for your enjoyment we
they've got to be fall after a frickin
mammoth nope they still want the deer
okay so the deer runs jumps over the
fire but what about the pond you jump
see you jump over the pond as well that
you did don't you do yeah it's got to be
the spear guys and maybe it got stopped
see there's I here yes it is I was ill
they can still run away Kobe ill so I
want mr. sphere where you got this
getting all these animal puzzle okay so
let's do this again oh you're already
all good good good good good a good good
good good you can't run away from the
sphere now you're dead and feed you to
my friends on the TP were suckers you be
what what so good stuff to do dan okay
um do they want a cooked mushroom do
they want to cook mushrooms no hmm
there's no fish
huh okay you have baked ok fish really
gonna go for the mushroom all right said
this game I guess well right there
doesn't really work as expected ok show
this again and then just put it on the
fire just cook the mushroom then I guess
yeah yum yum yum and then you can give
the mushroom wait what not that batch
will be ok now now you can do I guess if
it works it works right yeah we can see
you hear all the needs for our hungry
hungry friends because they don't they
obviously don't like vegetables to
terminate the mushroom they have a child
no wonder they were so hungry they were
giving breath ok fair enough I'm glad
you're happy yeah I agree thank you so
why did we work so hard together nice x
don't know why did we
hey dog I've got a little nice when I
don't know why can you tell me what's
what p Nana Nana okay hey maybe for the
blended no oh we can give this way as
well while I get them same booth guys
you've seen booth let's have a little
listen
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not being gifted with music
challenge spirit but
[Music]
this dream yo yo very much enjoyed oh
honey I can go over here cool i like the
listening function weird different i
think was giving us a clue of what to do
with a nice but i don't think i'll try
that thanks weirdo maybe you're using
iphone you yeah I do what the hell is he
doing ok hi Sarah haven't met you yet
but here's a list that you probably
asked for oh you go to your spaceship
how Union chair control box you got to
the top I know you need to bottom ok
okay oh where am I gonna find the other
piece mm-hmm you're so pretty go we
still got the knife so you can soon as
if other things can happen now he
doesn't wanna hurt animals that's cute I
respect that
hi little friend you going that way I'll
follow oh no it didn't go to it wonder
if we can get back inside oh we can okay
let's have a little look inside our
house dirty bathtubs what the hell am i
doing was learned about class Oh
partnership I don't like to know what
I'm doing us all in this game do i but
progressing anyway so that's good 12
gotcha all right I need a chair and the
controller let's have another quick look
in my little room and then I think I'll
leave it then be a quick one show you
guys games see how you like it and if
you want to see more I'm a journey so
far I am definitely enjoying this it's
exactly what I was hoping for brings you
back to my childhood keep Freight got a
frickin chair as well I might as well
just get it all now my name got the
chair
what the other thing we need our control
pod I wonder if I'll be in my house
[Music]
is that all we need now the control pod
ez pz clean it up okay so control pod
we're ever gonna find out this is just a
little book it up yo y'all we gotta what
if I mighty yari oh sweet what what does
this even mean oh well it will look see
that next time we'll have a proper good
read of this book put it away put your
little story by the way miss it and have
a little look appear you can look at all
the different windows anything in live
okay get down can't see Oh looking at us
wouldn't that be so weird if you just
saw like a huge face looking back in cuz
it's looking out oh there is something
who you just get to look into space like
that I'm gonna leave that there guys I
really love the looks of this game at
the moment the art style is gorgeous I
knew it was going to be the audio is
brilliant and some of the characters are
meeting already I was so crappy and
weird so next episode on a look for that
control box and we'll be back in space I
think never know if you do actually want
to see more of this sort of course
because I don't know unless you leave a
like or a comment telling me that you
want to see more so you do that i very
much appreciate it and have a lovely day
or evening bye
you